leg crushed and then eaten by a mutated
boa constrictor make good art I get
puzzled and lost when people start
asking me questions about what they
should be writing for the market
whatever there is no market saying that
we have an artist is like saying we have
enough scientists we have enough
designers I tended to do anything as
long as it felt like an adventure and to
stop when it felt like work I would try
and write things that was so brilliant
that nobody could reject them do lots
and lots of little trial projects do
lots end your trial balloons out float
your dandelion seeds he's an English
author of novels comic books and films
he's won numerous awards for his works
he's the first author to win the
Newberry and Carnegie award for the same
book he's Neil Gaiman and here is my
take on his top ten rules of success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick around all the
way to the end first
remember whatever discipline you're in
whether you're a musician or a
photographer a fine artist or a
cartoonist a writer a dancer singer a
designer whatever you do you have one
thing that's unique you have the ability
to make art and for me and for so many
of the people I've known that's been a
lifesaver
the ultimate lifesaver it gets you
through good times and it gets you
through the other ones sometimes life is
hard things go wrong in life and in love
and in business and in friendship and in
health and in all the other ways that
life can go wrong and when things get
tough this is what you should do make
good art I'm serious
husband runs off with a politician make
good art leg crushed and then eaten by a
mutated boa constrictor make good art
IRS on your trail make good art cat cat
exploded make good art someone on the
internet thinks what you're doing is
stupid or evil or it's all been done
before make good art probably things
will work out somehow eventually time
will take the sting away that doesn't
even matter do what only you can do best
make good art make it on the bad days
make it on the good days to write things
people want to read write things you
care about don't you know I get I get
puzzled and lost when people start
asking me questions about what they
should be writing for the market
whatever there is no market nobody
there's nobody in the whole world of
marketing ever would have woken up one
day and said a series of unfortunate
events is exact
what the world needs us you know nobody
would have turned around and gone are
your market niche is do a sort of reply
to Kipling's The Jungle Book
that's not you know things like that
happen because somebody wants to tell a
story and because you have an idea
because you think you can tell that's
very better than anybody else I always
mean to write
sequels people say why don't you write
sequels Neil Gaiman does not write
sequels like it well actually it's not
like I'm standing up you're I shall
never write a sequel there are sequels
I'd love to write but I I'm much more
likely to go Oh shiny when confronted by
something I have no idea how to do find
something over here that I really do
know how to do when I figured it out I
learned how to do it the last time and
everybody loved it and there are people
waiting and then over here is something
I have no idea what it is and nobody's
waiting for it I don't even think
anybody's really gonna like it I will do
that thing because that's that's cool
and it's new when you start out on a
career in the arts you have no idea what
you're doing this is great people who
know what they're doing know the rules
and they know what is possible and what
is impossible you do not and you should
not the rules on what is possible and
impossible in the arts were made by
people who had not tested the bounds of
the possible by going beyond them and
you can if you don't know it's
impossible it's easier to do and because
nobody's done it before they haven't
made up rules to stop anyone doing that
particular thing again saying that we
have enough artists is like saying we
have enough scientists we have enough
designers we have enough politicians we
have enough politics
you know nobody gets to be you except
you nobody has your point of view except
you nobody gets to bring to the world
the things that you get to bring to the
world uniquely get to bring to the world
except you
so saying there are enough writers out
there enough directors out there enough
people with points of view well yeah
there are but none of them are you and
none of them none of those people is
going to make the art that you will make
none of them will change people and
change the world in the way that you
could change it so if you believe
somebody who says no no we've got enough
of those then all it means is you're
giving up your chance to change the
world in the way that only you could
change it um so do you have any advice
for someone who would like to start
doing creative writing but has no idea
where to start whatsoever um depends are
you the kind of person who arm do you
read a lot I read a lot yes
and I write snarky emails but that's bad
I've been told they're very good I mean
when you say creative writing do you
want to write fiction do you want to
write humorous essays do you want to
there's an election I would think you
want to do stories yes okay so my advice
is start writing stories just like do it
um really it's almost as simple as that
it's start writing so pick a bigger
style pick a theme look at the kind of
you know you are not expected straight
out of the Hat to be a brave and
original voice producing fine and
wonderful fiction it's much more like
you know the first pancake on the
griddle which is going to be this weird
black messy thing that you will either
give to your dog or to a child
try to convince them yeah it's nice hey
you know it's you you right you finish
things you start the next thing you
write that you finish it someone there
you get reasonably good arm any of these
two people or do you just yeah I the the
point I was found that I I would always
learn more about what I'd done the
moment I saw it in print or the moment
these days probably the moment you'd see
things up on the web but yeah
shown to people um but the most
important thing when you're just
starting out is write the next one
assume that you have you know a million
words inside you that are absolute
rubbish and you need to get them out
before you get to the good ones and if
you get there early that's great that
that's really my biggest advice thank
you read everything you can read outside
your comfort zone and write a lot if you
have an idea of what you want to make
what you were put here to do then just
go and do that and that's much harder
than it sounds and sometimes in the end
so much easier than you might imagine
because normally there are things you
have to do before you can get to the
place you want to be
I wanted to write comics and novels and
stories and films so I became a
journalist because journalists are
allowed to ask questions and to simply
go and find out how the world works
and besides to do those things I needed
to write and to write well and I was
being paid to learn how to write
economically crisply sometimes under
adverse conditions and on deadlines
sometimes the way to do what you hope to
do will be clear-cut and sometimes it'll
be almost impossible to decide whether
or not you're doing the correct thing
because you'll have to balance your
goals and hopes with feeding yourself
paying debts finding work settling for
what you can get something that worked
for me was imagining that where I wanted
to be which was an author primarily a
fiction
making good books making good comics
making good drama and supporting myself
through my words imagining that was a
mountain a distant mountain my goal and
I knew that as long as I kept walking
towards the mountain
I'd be all right and when I truly was
not sure what to do I could stop and
think about whether it was taking me
towards or away from the mountain I said
no to editorial jobs on magazines proper
jobs that would have paid proper money
because I knew that attractive though
they were for me they would have been
walking away from the mountain and if
those job offers had come earlier I
might have taken them because they still
would have been closer to the mountain
than I was at that time I learned to
write by writing I tended to do anything
as long as it felt like an adventure and
to stop when it felt like work which
meant that life did not feel like work
one of the things that happens
especially when you're starting out is
you write stories and you send them out
in my head as a young man whenever I
would send out a story what I would
expect to have happen was the following
morning a limo would show up at my house
and people would get out of it and they
would say this is yours we loved your
story so much you never have to work
again just thank you thank you for
writing this story which we are going to
publish and make sure everybody in the
whole world reads and and instead you
know six weeks later it would come back
with a little slip saying not quite
right for us whatever um it was okay you
know did what what you do is what I did
two different things um what I did as a
very young man was get things back and
go either I'm not very good which I
do not choose to believe although
probably with kind of true or I'm just
doing this wrong and I need to find out
how this all works so that was the point
where um I became a journalist and I
became a journalist specializing in
publishing in books and I found out how
it all worked and and you know two
months later had sold two books and then
got a quote from Muddy Waters which I
stuck to my typewriter
which tells you how long ago this was
and it just said don't let your mouth
right now check your tail can't cash
that was my quote hell I went how did I
just sold two books I've never written a
book what am i doing and I got through
it my tail cash those checks but um
really I kind of dealt with it by just
bowing to myself that you know I would
try and write things that were so
brilliant that nobody could reject them
do lots of things try lots of things I
think the comparison of dandelion seeds
think dandelion seeds dandelions mammals
traditionally spend a lot of time
building a new mammal like them it's a
lot of a lot of time an investment in
food and investment everything
dandelions they just have a head with
lots of dandelion seeds and they let
them go and the idea is that some of
them will survive most of them won't
survive but that's okay because a few
dandelion seeds are going to go off and
they will make more dandelions and I
would counsel people to think like that
now starting off in the world that we're
in there's this peculiar
world where we don't know what the rules
are everything's changing so do lots and
lots of little trial projects do not
send your trial balloons out float your
dandelion seeds absolutely be happy for
five things that you do to fail if one
succeeds and one succeeds well just try
more don't be locked down I think that
that would be my big piece of advice
right so when I agreed to give this
address I thought what is the best piece
of advice I was ever given and I
realized that it was actually a piece of
advice that I had failed to follow then
it came from Stephen King it was 20
years ago at the height of the success
the initial success of Sandman the comic
I was writing I was oh thank you I was
writing a comic people loved and they
were taking it seriously and Stephen
King lights and man and my novel would
Terry Pratchett Good Omens and he he saw
the madness that was going on in the
long signing lines all of that stuff
that and his advice to me was this he
said this is really great you should
enjoy it and I didn't best advice I ever
got that I ignored instead I worried
about it I worried about the next
deadline the next idea
the next story there wasn't a moment for
the next 14 or 15 years that I wasn't
writing something in my head or
wondering about it and I didn't stop and
look and look around and go this is
really fun
I wish I'd enjoyed it more it's been an
amazing ride but there were parts of the
ride I missed because I was too worried
about things going wrong about what came
next to enjoy the bit that I was on that
was the hardest lesson for me I think to
let go and enjoy the ride because the
ride takes used to some remarkable and
unexpected places
and here on this platform today for me
is one of those places and I am enjoying
myself immensely
you
thank you so much for watching I made
this beauty because Benjamin's survi
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur you want me to program that
leave it in the comments below and I'll
see what I can do I also love to know
which of the top
the biggest impact on you and why what
change you're going to make now in your
business after watching this video leave
it down in the comments and I will join
in the discussion thank you so much for
watching
to believe whatever your one word is
soon
if you're feeling it particularly at a
creative low point where you get your
inspiration from to come up with such
amazing tales and amazing subject matter
to write stories about um what you've
actually done there is ask the question
that must not be asked of writers you've
rephrased ever so slightly but what you
fundamentally does say where do you get
your ideas and writers are awful to
people who ask us where we get our ideas
we get mean we don't just get mean we
get mean in a writer II way which means
we'll make fun of you and and we do that
not afraid and the reason we do that is
because we don't really know and we
terrified the ideas will go away so
every writer I know has a funny answer
and and you know Harlan Ellison used to
say that he got them from a little idea
shop in Schenectady and your writer who
when asked would say he gets them from
the idea of the Month Club and people
get really here's all you every month
they send you an idea
the truth is I think um for me
inspiration comes through a bunch of
places
desperation deadlines a lot of times
ideas will turn up while you're doing
something else and most of all I think
ideas come from confluence they come
from two things flowing together they
come from essentially from daydreaming
it's that point and I suspect is
something that every human being does
writers came to train themselves to
notice when they've had an idea it's not
that they have any more ideas or get
inspired more than anything else we just
we just notice when it happens a little
bit more but you're just thinking you're
you go wow you know everybody knows that
if you get bitten by a werewolf when the
moon is full you will turn into a wolf
you know that
there's that moment where you're sitting
thinking so what happens if a werewolf
bites a goldfish
and or that moment where you start
thinking well actually what happens if a
werewolf sinks its fangs into a chair
and what if you're sitting in that chair
and the moonlight touches it and slowly
it starts feeling more and more wolfish
and then it growls and and you know and
then what about the oh my god and then
then you'd have to set it in the winter
because you'd need the snow for people
to try and figure out why you've got
chair leg marks in the snow by the body
that's had its throat ripped out and
suddenly you have a story so that's so
it's a lot of it is daydreaming I wish
there was something I always feel I'm in
some ways disappointing people when they
ask where do you get your inspiration
because what they really always want is
the answer they want you to be able to
say well what you do is 11:58 at night
you go down to the cellar you roll the
goat bones
there'll be a banging on the door it
will open this thing will fly in it will
explode you'll have a something like a
chocolate you eat it you have an idea
I don't know you make him out a day
ahead when you start out you have to
deal with the problems of failure you
need to be thick-skinned to learn that
not every project will survive a
freelance life a life in the arts is
sometimes like putting messages in
bottles on a desert island and hoping
that someone will find one of your
bottles and open it and read it and put
something in a bottle that will wash its
way back to you
appreciation or a commission or money or
love and you have to accept that you may
put out hundreds of things for every
bottle that winds up coming back the
problems of failure the problems of
discouragement of hopelessness of hunger
you want everything to happen and you
want it now and things go wrong my first
book a piece of journalism I done only
for the money and which had already
bought me an electric typewriter from
the advance should have been a
best-seller it should have played me a
lot of money if the publisher hadn't
gone into involuntary liquidation
between the first print run selling out
and the second print run never happening
and before any Broyles could be paid it
would have done and I shrugged and I
still have my electric typewriter and
enough money to pay the rent for a
couple of months and I decided that I'd
do my best in future not to write books
just for the money if you didn't get the
money then you didn't have anything and
if I did work I was proud of and I
didn't get the money at least I'd have
the work every now and then I forget
that rule and whenever I do the universe
kicks me hard and reminds me I don't
know that it's an issue for anybody but
me but it's true that nothing I did
we're the only reason for doing it was
the money was ever worth it except as
bitter experience usually I didn't wind
up getting the money either
the things I did because I was excited
and wanted to see them exist in reality
have never let me down and I've never
regretted the time I spent on any of
them